you because your partner is a reflection
of you who you choose is a reflection of
you then that does play a part in him
thinking okay is this somebody who I
want to represent me to the world does
that make sense so it I think you know
like Chris you said you've got a name
right yeah right and you're Nigerian
yeah you start Nigerian so respect in
our culture is huge massive and there
are a lot of other cultures like Asian
cultures like there are a lot of a lot
of other cultures where respect is very
important so yeah I think um I think
that's when you say about being a man
part of being a man is having the level
of respect that you desire which is you
know a lot of guys may look at Will
Smith and be like
he doesn't have a lot of respect right
now do you know what I mean and he
hasn't for a long time I think
everybody wants to be respected and I
completely and again another
like societies that are much more
Collective they're way less
individualistic like UK especially
American society very individualistic
whereas if you're taking countries Asia
Africa there is a lot more uh uh
importance on what Society is a whole
and how you fit into society yeah the
community and I think that's a really
good thing in some senses but those
countries also have some of the highest
rates of suicide because they have so
much socialism sorry
um
third world countries yeah but I would
say they actually have the lowest rates
which is confused a lot of social
scientists yeah like they have less look
at like Japan it has one of the highest
rates because of social stigma and shame
if they do something wrong
when I went to Japan like my my
understanding was it was more like one
um it's a very individualistic Society
like so yeah like people are dying alone
in their apartment there oh yeah and
like and and men are working themselves
today death so I don't I don't think
it's like social stigma but I don't I'm
not saying in terms of people I'm not
talking about people's isolation because
Japan also has a problem with not enough
people are having children yeah I know
because it's back to like the
individualistic like like Japan has a
problem with like women like that like
getting old and not being able to find
husbands basically right now but but
historically and it's still the case
that they have very clear social rules
like even in terms of things if you
would never hold hands with your partner
or use your partner on the street
because societally that's like that's
frowned upon socially really because I I
went there when I was younger and like
that the couple I stayed with like they
were I don't know that was not the case
it's the same it's like that in UAE
they're very strict about like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so and I'm saying
more that the thing with with with with
guys and this thing of okay I want to be
respected by my men and I completely see
that and I completely see that and and
especially in other countries where that
is even more important or different
culture is where that's really important
and what being a man is differently
defined I think that's why it's
important to shift the societal
Narrative of what we Define as being a
good man as what we because I think it's
a lot of pressure
things just like are like I'm never
gonna because when we're saying we need
to change society that's just like you
putting your world view onto society and
saying this is how you should think
I don't you know what I'm saying like
like because we have inter like like
this is what I mean when I say we feel
shame like that's that's a natural
instinct and there's a reason like
everyone feels the same like there's a
reason men respect the president of the
United States and look at that as a
successful man like there's a reason
like women are attracted to power
ambition like some stuff I don't think
we can just tell ourselves not to do it
just like is and I think for sure
there's a certain element of we you know
you can't always make someone think the
same way as you I can't magically Force
the UAE to be Progressive overnight I
can't make them respect women I can't
change like I as an individual can't
help these things and I completely
understand that for some societies some
cultures they don't want that they don't
want me to come in and be like well I
think but without things like that we'd
still have FGM being acceptable
which is is really widespread especially
in Africa like and the more that we talk
about that and say actually that's
really not acceptable and I know a lot
of people make the argument the fallacy
of tradition we talk about in philosophy
the fallacy of tradition it's like just
because it's a traditional thing doesn't
mean it's a good thing or the right
thing or it benefits people so I think
there's I think it's a give and take
thing I think it's a thing of no you
shouldn't force your worldview and you
shouldn't force your opinion learn title
to their opinion but I think sometimes
it's like these things actually Aid
people somewhere I would never want a
man to think you know he has to act this
way because without the respect of
someone else and he cares really what
this guy thinks then he's less of a man
and he's less of a man than who is he
I'm like I couldn't care do you think
that's just like even when you say like
I don't want to say less of a man
because it's like
I just feel like that's like dishonest
like there's hierarchies in every like
every society of life and you can't say
like pretend they don't exist doesn't
make them not exist so for example like
a Victoria's Secret model is hotter than
me and if you're gonna like come up to
me and say like oh you're just as hot
like you could say that
like but that's that's life and it's the
same thing with like guys there's
hierarchies with like men in terms of
like and because a lot of it's like they
men value like other men like they pick
it like they they pick who they respect
and who they don't like yeah I mean yeah
this this hierarchy in in everything
whether that's attractiveness or your
kind of social standing and you see it I
was saying before you see it so much in
schools in terms of popular kind of
popularity groups and I think it becomes
more redundant when you're in kind of
day-to-day Society but I think the
problem with this this thing of what
what makes a good man or woman what
makes a good woman
it's not only are they kind of two
different things but I think that
they're abstract and I think in the same
way we go what is our net what is what
is a Great British value I think it's
supply and demand it's like Supply like
when we go to talk about a good band and
a good woman it's supply and demand it's
like who who do the most men want and
who do the most women want
you know I I just think goodness is is
tied much more to
who you are as a person and less about
okay what do other people think of you
and actually do you treat people nicely
I think that I feel like a good man is
the same thing as what a good woman is
right but usually like
I don't think we're debate what a good
man is I think I think the original
point was just that he was I think when
you're saying more of a man I think it
was what we would call a good example of
what a man could be and is
part of that or what contributes to that
is him having a respectable partner or a
perceived respectable partner because I
keep using this because it's fresh but
like Will Smith he's a good man
but I don't think he's been respected
for a long time
yeah he's not been respected as a man
for a long especially with his
relationship but he's a very good man I
just I just don't think putting
limitations especially on the situation
of like and this is this isn't an attack
on you at all of what you said it's more
just like the phrasing of it makes me go
like well because I think
um not me you can say it
no it doesn't make me think don't say it
it's more that I think
um I think that putting putting a
limitation on your partner in order to
make you seem more respectable is not
necessarily healthy well women do that
to men though
that doesn't make it healthy
nah I feel like it um the quality of the
woman or like for example if she has her
own just for like for example it does
affect you as a man for example look at
Will Smith before before we knew all
this stuff we knew about Jada right we
thought Will Smith was like
on the show